Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
L’Océan, avenir de la Terre,
la mer, avenir de la planète bleue.
Notre avenir s'écrit dans l'océan.
Tous nos médias le déclarent
d’une manière péremptoire :
notre avenir se jouera en mer.
Ils ont raison.
Une grande partie des solutions
à nos problématiques actuelles
se trouvent en mer.
La faim dans le monde
avec l’aquaculture ou l’algoculture,
les besoins en énergies renouvelables
avec l’éolien offshore,
le houlomoteur, l’hydrolien,
la santé avec l’utilisation
des organismes marins
ou bien encore le transport bas carbone
avec le retour de la marine à voile
ou la propulsion à hydrogène.
Alors, me direz-vous,
même sur des sujets très terrestres
comme Internet ou le numérique,
l’océan n’est jamais très loin.
Par exemple, la toile Web n’est
véritablement devenue mondiale
que grâce à l’existence
des câbles sous-marins.
Sans doute,
l’économie maritime est-elle
pleine de projets innovants
et de prototypes en train de démontrer
leur capacité aux quatre coins du monde.
Eh bien non !
Je peux en témoigner.
Il y a dix ans,
j’ai quitté les Chantiers de l’Atlantique,
une société de stature mondiale,
pour repartir de zéro et créer, avec mon
associé Philippe Magaldi, GEPS Techno.
Notre ADN :
l’innovation dans le monde maritime.
Notre vision : le projet Mliner,
une plateforme flottante capable
de combiner quatre sources d’énergie,
le vent, la houle,
le soleil et le courant.
Notre objectif : être capable de délivrer
une électricité renouvelable peu coûteuse
partout autour du monde.
Et nous nous imaginions déjà
quelques mois plus tard,
avec le Mliner en train
de flotter devant Saint-Nazaire.
Pourtant...
Pourtant, dix ans après, le Mliner
n’est toujours pas en mer.
Dix ans après,
nous avons rencontré une à une
toutes les barrières qui s’opposent
aux projets innovants du monde maritime.
Nous avons rencontré des décideurs
politiques et investisseurs
qui n’ont jamais mis les pieds en mer
et considèrent les projets maritimes de la
même manière que les projets terrestres.
Nous avons rencontré des conflits
entre usagers du monde maritime.
La mer est le bien commun de l’humanité,
mais certains voudraient bien
garder le bien commun pour eux.
La sanctuarisation des littoraux
dans nos pays civilisés.
Avant, vous pouviez faire à peu
près n'importe quoi en mer.
De nos jours, il est interdit de toucher
au moindre grain de sable.
Derrière toutes ces barrières,
un point commun : la peur de l’inconnu.
La peur de l’inconnu,
elle est bien naturelle.
À titre personnel,
je suis né il y a 50 ans
en plein centre de la France, en Auvergne.
Rien ne me prédestinait à travailler
pour l’économie maritime.
Si j'avais bien la chance de passer
une grande partie de mes vacances
au bord de la mer,
c’était toujours en Méditerranée.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que mon père, des années avant,
avait passé deux jours à l’Île de Ré
et en était revenu
avec une conviction profonde :
l’Atlantique, c’est l’enfer.
Des vagues monstrueuses, des marées
piégeuses, une eau sombre et froide.
Quand je suis venu des années plus tard
pour travailler aux Chantiers,
il m’a fallu quelques mois
pour surmonter ces a priori
et m’apercevoir que la vie
sur la presqu’île était bien agréable.
Le chemin que j’ai fait
pour passer outre ces a priori,
il faut le faire dans le domaine
de l’innovation maritime
et passer outre nos a priori.
Pour cela, après dix ans d’expérience
dans GEPS Techno,
je propose une méthode simple :
tester, mesurer et coopérer.
Tester.
Pour avancer, il faut oser.
Et oser, ça veut dire quitter nos écrans
d’ordinateur, quitter le laboratoire,
quitter les bassins de tests
et aller en mer.
Ça vous paraît une évidence ?
Aujourd'hui, je suis entouré de porteurs
de projets maritimes qui m'expliquent
qu'ils ont fait toutes les simulations
numériques pour tous les états de mer,
qu’ils ont fait tous les tests en bassin
pour tous les états de mer,
et que donc il ne sert à rien d’aller en
mer puisque tout se passera comme prévu
et qu’ils peuvent passer
à l’échelle industrielle.
Lorsque nous avons mis notre premier
prototype à l’eau, chez GEPS Techno,
c’était une plateforme autonome.
Au bout de quelques semaines,
nous avions perdu 50 % de la puissance
de nos panneaux solaires.
Les responsables ? Les mouettes.
Nos logiciels de simulation n’avaient pas
prévu la fiente des mouettes
sur les panneaux solaires.
(Rires)
Quelques piques à pigeons plus tard,
et une rambarde pour que les oiseaux
puissent quand même se poser sur la bouée,
nous avions récupéré notre puissance
des panneaux solaires.
Ce n’est qu’un exemple, des exemples
comme ça, j’en ai des dizaines.
Mais ces périodes de tests en mer
sont aussi une bonne leçon d’humilité.
Elle nous confronte à nos échecs
et nous donne aussi l’occasion de rebondir
et de trouver de nouvelles solutions.
Je sais que nous avons choisi
d’aller très vite en mer,
quatorze mois
après la création de la société.
Nous sommes en novembre 2012
sur le site de tests de l’Ifremer
et nous allons mettre
notre première bouée à l’eau.
Nous mettons notre bouée à l’eau
et la bouée s’incline
et reste parfaitement immobile.
Or on ne peut produire d’énergie que si
elle suit le mouvement des vagues.
Bon.
Première modification.
La bouée reste inclinée, immobile.
Il va nous falloir six mois
de modifications
et on va le refaire régulièrement.
On va recalculer, on va re-simuler
et à chaque fois, la bouée
reste inclinée et immobile.
Aujourd’hui, ce problème est derrière nous
et nos bouées commerciales
cumulent près de 400 000 heures
à bouger et produire de l’électricité.
Mais cette période-là reste bien gravée
dans la tête de notre petite équipe
et nous encourage à franchir
de nouveaux écueils
à chaque fois qu’ils se présentent.
Les périodes de tests en mer, c’est
aussi une vraie garantie de crédibilité.
Imaginez-vous faire visiter
à un client un prototype
qui revient de deux ans en mer
où tout est en parfait ordre,
où tout fonctionne
et où tout est propre, net ?
La crédibilité acquise à ce moment-là
est primordiale.
Alors, en même temps que tester,
il faut mesurer.
Un des enjeux qui se cachent
derrière la peur de l’inconnu,
c’est le fait de pouvoir éradiquer
nos peurs et nos fantasmes
et donc disposer de l’impact réel
des technologies.
Quand je dis « impact réel »,
ça veut dire disposer de données
objectives, quantifiées, permanentes,
avec des capteurs
et des méthodes de mesure reconnus.
C’est le métier d’Agrocéan, la première
société à avoir acheté nos bouées.
Celles qui produisent de l’énergie,
pas celles qui sont inclinées, immobiles.
La mission d’Agrocéan, c’est de
s’installer sur un champ éolien
et de faire ce qu’on appelle l’état zéro.
C’est-à-dire que,
avant l’existence du champ,
ils vont venir mesurer exactement
ce qui se passe dans l’environnement -
établir un état zéro -
puis ils suivront
l’évolution de l’environnement
pendant la construction du champ éolien,
puis pendant son exploitation.
Ça veut dire surveiller
énormément de choses.
Par exemple, si certaines espèces de
poissons voient leur population grandir,
à l’inverse, si certaines populations
disparaissent.
Mais ça veut dire aller beaucoup
plus loin : suivre également
le changement de comportement
des cétacés, des oiseaux,
d’énormément de choses sur le champ.
Ces données nous renseignent sur
l’impact réel des technologies sur place.
On voit l'évolution de l'environnement.
Mais plus intéressant,
elles vont pouvoir être injectées
dans des modèles numériques
pour prévoir ce qui va se passer.
Avec l’avènement du Big Data
et du jumeau numérique,
ce sont désormais des choses
qui sont très intéressantes
puisqu’on peut suivre l’évolution
de l’environnement sur plusieurs années.
Également important, c’est que ces
technologies nous permettent de réagir.
Évidemment, la simulation numérique
ne va pas donner la situation réelle.
Et donc, parfois,
il faut être capable de réagir
sur ce qui est en train de se passer
parce qu’il y a un paramètre qui
dérive et qu’on n’avait pas prévu.
Ces mesures sont très utiles
pour l’information et la formation
de l’ensemble des publics,
des parties prenantes intéressées
par ces nouvelles technologies.
Bien sûr le pouvoir public,
mais aussi les organisations
non-gouvernementales et le grand public.
Il est important que chacune
de ces parties prenantes
ait la connaissance de l’évolution
de l’impact réel de ces technologies
pour être capable de prendre
les bonnes orientations à l’avenir.
Enfin, après avoir testé et mesuré,
il faut coopérer.
Pourquoi coopérer ?
Parce que coopérer, c’est partager
ses acquis et ses compétences,
les mettre en commun
et accélérer le développement.
C’est ce qu’on appelle
la fertilisation croisée.
Par exemple, sur le projet Dikwe,
avec la société Legendre,
nous avons décidé de développer
une digue à énergie positive,
c’est-à-dire une digue qui est
capable d’accueillir des bateaux
et de protéger le littoral
de l’assaut des vagues,
mais, en même temps, qui est capable
de récupérer cette énergie
pour produire de l’électricité
et la donner au réseau.
Legendre a amené toutes ses connaissances
des travaux portuaires et du génie civil.
Et nous, GEPS Techno,
on a fait comme d’habitude,
on a récupéré l’énergie des vagues
et on a converti cette énergie.
Le fait de partager nos compétences
nous a permis d’aller beaucoup plus vite.
Et dès 2024, il y aura une première
digue de ce type-là en Bretagne.
Coopérer, ça veut quand même dire
qu’il faut conserver les acquis de chacun.
Aujourd’hui, un des enjeux
dans la coopération,
c’est de protéger les jeunes sociétés
des grands groupes.
Pourquoi ?
La majorité des contrats en vigueur
aujourd’hui disent que, pour faire simple,
lorsqu’un grand groupe signe une commande
avec une petite société comme nous,
il dispose ensuite de la totale liberté
d’utiliser toutes ses connaissances,
gratuitement, mais à son profit exclusif.
Or aujourd’hui,
les technologies de rupture qui permettent
de résoudre les problèmes de demain,
elles viennent de ces petites structures,
pas des grands services R&D.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que dans les petites structures,
on n'a pas peur de l'échec.
On va oser des choses qui vont permettre
de développer ces technologies de rupture.
Meta l’a très bien compris.
Il est venu nous voir
il y a deux ans en disant :
« Je veux multiplier la capacité de mes
câbles sous-marins Internet par dix.
Mais j’ai un problème : il me faut
de l’électricité au milieu de l’océan. »
Depuis deux ans,
nous avons collaboré avec Meta
et, dès le début, ils ont accepté
qu’on puisse aller voir leurs concurrents,
qu’on puisse tirer profit
de tout ce qu’on allait apprendre.
Ils ont même imaginé aujourd’hui
mettre cette technologie
à disposition de la totalité
de leurs concurrents
et des autres entreprises du monde.
Quand on est
dans un tel esprit de collaboration,
on arrive à créer un cerveau collectif
d’une puissance remarquable
parce que chacun contribue
à un objectif global
et ne va pas se demander s’il doit
garder des choses pour lui ou pas.
Cette évolution porte pour moi,
je l’espère,
une évolution positive
de notre monde économique :
le partage de la connaissance
et la capacité à résoudre au plus vite les
problèmes qui nous occupent aujourd’hui.
En conclusion, je voudrais vous dire :
faites confiance aux innovateurs
du monde maritime.
Nous sommes tous
entrepreneurs pour réussir.
Mais nous sommes aussi et surtout
tous entrepreneurs
pour réussir à régler
les problèmes du monde de demain.
Après tout,
si j’ai été capable de passer outre les
a priori que m’avait inculqués mon père,
vous pouvez certainement
passer outre vos doutes
et être capable d’accueillir
avec bienveillance
les projets innovants du monde maritime.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)